Hi, I'm Kagure Kabue. I'm from Kenya, originally,
but I live in San Francisco now. I have
darkly pigmented skin, and I lived in an
area that had a high prevalence for sickle-cell anemia.
>> Well, we're really happy that you are interviewing with
us for, for the class today. you get to talk
to us about two traits in two different lessons for
us and one of the first traits we learned about
is skin pigmentation. And that the idea
that everyone originally, all humans had darkly pigmented
skin and that then as we migrated out of Africa, we went to various locations.
And because we needed more sunlight in our skin, and melanin was keeping it out,
that many people started getting mutations that
made them lose melanin pigment in their skin.
>> Mm-hm.
>> so,
the i, you know, the fact that you're from
Kenya, right brings us back to our ancestral origins.
all humans originated originally in Africa, and there are
some great fossils, amazing fossils, in Kenya, in particular and
so a lot of human history, really originated in,
in sort of that region. I just wanted, can you
tell us a little bit about Kenya for those
of us who never visited or am sorry, should say,
for anybody whose never been to Kenya, what's Kenya like, is it hot, is it.
>> Well, it depends on the region, and so if you're further down at the coast,
well first of all Kenya's in East Africa
and it's right under the horn of Africa, so
under Somalia and above Tanzania. And we have
the Indian Ocean to our East so, if
you're closer to the coast, it's much hotter,
it's just hot at the coast, especially in January.
and we're right on the equator, the country is actually almost split in half,
by the line, equator line. And if you live up in the highlands, like
I do, which is on the slopes of Mount Kenya, the temperature doesn't vary much,
so it will only be a few degrees celsius different from morning to evening.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And so you can wear a sweater or not if you want, or not.
>> And it, it's beautiful. You should check out
the Kenyan government web site for more information, lots of
[LAUGH]
Lions and.
>> Ooh, lions?
>> Yeah.
>> So if you don't live on the slope, if
you actually live in, I guess closer to the coast maybe.
>> Mm-hm.
>> how hot does it get there?
>> I couldn't tell you off the top of my head but, you know, especially
with the conversion rates but, it gets hot
enough that you should probably just stay indoors.
>>
[LAUGH]
Stay indoors?
>>
[LAUGH]
Yeah, don't go outside.
>>
and what about the scenery? You, you moved to San Francisco,
is is it more beautiful in San Francisco or in Kenya?
>> Each place has it's, you know, it's attractions and some things
are more beautiful here than they are back home and vice versa.
>> Mm hmm
>> But, in general, it's just different. It's
hard to compare the two because it's so different.
>> Right.
>> San Francisco is a city and it has it's appeal in that way, and where I
grew up I lived in a town that had a pineapple plantation and that had its
charm as well, as well as coffee and
waterfalls and all these things. So it's just different.
>> Yeah, do you get to go back and visit?
>> Sometimes.
>> Yeah.
>> I try and go back once a year, but you know, to get braces, airlines.
>> I was about to say.
>> Yeah.
>> It's expensive but I'm sure you're family loves that.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> And I like it too.
>> Right. so, you know, there, there's no stepping around sort of the the, the
obvious issue that people in different continents on the globe have different
colored skin and that is caused by the different amounts of melanin that they
have deposited by melanocytes into the, the skin itself. so give us some idea,
you know, in Kenya are most people, do they
have dark skin, do you they have light skin?
>> I would say most people have dark skin
because it, I guess it's, is it a sliding scale, what's dark skin and what's not
dark skin? But most people would probably on
the and where your skin is considered dark.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And that's just how I grew up with everybody
around me looking like I did with slight variations in shade.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But pretty much.
>> You know, that's interesting that you put it
like that I mean, you know, I'm someone who's
lightly pigmented and, and I don't remember exactly when I
noticed, like people, I grew up in an area
that was probably about 50%-ish, sort of like, either you
where either lightly pigmented or you were darkly pigmented.
And I remember I was probably, I don't know, middle
school when I started realizing, sort of, oh, you know,
we don't have the same color skin. You know when
you grow up in an area where most people have the
same color skin. Do you, is there certain age that you're
sort of notice differences you know, with other people either you
know, where you were living or even outside where you were living.
>> Well, I had, the advantage or disadvantage of
going to a, an international school when I was
younger, and so there were a lot of Europeans
or people who were both European and African descent.
And, so, I don't know when I first
realized a difference. I don't remember, except maybe when
I came here and the absolute opposite was
happening where I was suddenly the minority. Whereas, where
I grew up people with lighter skin pigmentation
were the minority. And so, I don't know, I
think that was my first time to actually, you
know, realize, it when I moved here in 2008.
That, oh my goodness, this plane is full of people who do not like me. And...
>> So you moved from a place where you were the majority to a
place where you were in the minority
and I think, historically speaking, you know? There's
a lot of interesting questions in the
nexus of, you know just the human condition,
and how people treated others with different
skin colors over time, is you know have
many courses about that. But in Kenya in particular, is there any I mean how
do people think of Europeans, let's say or
in generally people with lightly colored skin overall
historically? What, what are the? How do
people put that into the context? How do
people treat people with different color skins and
think about that in the context of, history?
>> Well,
historically Kenya was colonized by Europeans, last lot being the British.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And so, there is something to say about a European coming
back into the country. I'm not sure I can't speak for all
generations and all people, but there are certain attitudes that prevail and
some which are more dominant in certain generations than in others; for example,
you'll have people who believe that, a
European or someone with lighter skin pigmentation is.
>> Mm hm
>> Meant to be in charge.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Because of that history of colonization, and then
there's the other end of that attitude, where someone else
might think to themselves, I don't want to see someone
who looks like that in charge because of the history.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And all the bad things that may have been associated
with the colonization. And then there's people outside of
the country who look to a country like Kenya
and say, we need a European or an outside
force to act as the face of the country
to show that it can be run well. Because
you know there's histories of violence and corruption and
all these other things in Africa in general. And
so there's, there's different attitudes, and then I hope, I'd,
I'd hope to say that with the younger generation it doesn't matter as much.
>> Mm-hm
>> although it's still something that you would notice.
>> And an education from another
country is usually considered something of value.
>> Mm-hm.
>> but that, that may not be a skin pigmentation thing.
>> For example myself getting an education
here and then going back there would
hopefully give me a leg up and that's the idea behind it.
>> Mm-hm. But then there's also the idea of myself and someone
with lighter skin pigmentation of European descent, having the same education or
the same exact background as I did, growing up in Kenya, coming
here, going back there. It's like, who would get the job and why?
>> Mm-hm.
>> And in that case I, there's the idea of this
person with lighter skin pigmentation might get that job that
I'm vying for, because they would act as a better face
to someone outside the country who might look in and see
oh, we can use this person to represent what we want.
>> I see. Wow, that's complicated.
>> But that's just one of the things
that could happen, there's so many, attitudes and so.
>> Right.
>> Many other things that could or could not happen.
>> Right. It seems that you know skin color's such an easy trade for people
to latch on to, you know.
>> Right.
>> They associate lots of other things with it.
historically I think this is like it's always been
true Do you think that in general and you
can speak from your perspective growing up in Kenya
or even from your experiences in San Francisco. Do
you think you know your generation or the current
generations perspective on skin color is different from past
generations in a, in a, in a better or
worse way?
>> I think its, I think it's better, but it's also very complicated because
there's that, sort of, love hate relationship that comes with a, a, country or a
people who've been, enslaved, or colonized. Where
you end up either identifying, because you, identify,
you, you connect those two traits, you'll
connect the, the wealth, and the success to
the skin pigmentation. And so, I hope to think that in a reverse
situation, where skin pigmentation, someone with
darker skin pigmentation had colonized a country.
>> Mm-hm.
>> That was full of like, an African person had gone, Shaka
Zulu went to, I don't know, Britain or something and colonized them.
>> Mm-hm.
>> That the opposite would happen, and
everyone would be outside trying to tan.
>>
[LAUGH].
>> And, I know,
[LAUGH],
I don't know if that would happen but, you
know? I like to think that that's how this
is broken down, it's not because one is better
or worse than the other. It's just, historically, there has
been a correlation or a connection between these two
and so people have tend to identify one with
success and one with failure. It just happens that
that's how it went down at this period in history.
>> I
really like that thought experiment. That's
a really good thought experiment to do.
>> Right. What's, so, even within Kenya, you know growing up, you said
most people are, have darker skin. You
know, do people still distinguish, obviously you
said too it's a spectrum, I mean,
do people still distinguish culturally, you know,
between a really darker skinned person versus
a maybe not as dark skinned person?
>> Right. Well, there are, people do because we
have many tribes in Kenya and certain tribes
will have certain features that, that are more
prevalent in their tribe. And if a certain
tribe has more dark, darker, people who are
darker, a lot more people who are, have
darker skin pigmentation, then when you see someone
else who has that same coloring, you'd think
to yourself,oh, they must be from that tribe."
>> I see.
>> And so, that's how,
which isn't always the case. You can sometimes, you know, want to try
and find someone who's lighter or darker than you'd expect them to be.
>> Sure.
>> But in general people will use their signifiers to categorize others.
>> That's actually used as an identifier for for purposes.
>> Yeah.
>> even though there aren't as, you know, There's not as big a difference in
the spectrum between let's say me and you on the color or pigmentation spectrum.
we could be treated very differently as you
said you know, by different people and different
cultures or different backgrounds just because of that.
Do people treat people differently in Kenya too, even
though, maybe there's not as much of a
difference in skin color or is there still
that kind of I guess we should say
discrimination that happens even based on more subtle changes?
>> I would, yes. Sort of. It's not blatant.
I don't think it would be discrimination,
I think it would be because certain people
associate these traits with positive things or negative
things. And so, if I personally thought to
myself, oh, that person has all these identifiers,
they have lighter skin, pigmentation. They have hair
that's a little bit straighter then I think to myself, oh they must be from the
North Eastern part of Kenya because they, they
have Somali blood in them or something like that.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And then, then from there after,
having identified them with a certain tribe
or a certain group of people then, personally what do I think of those people.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And so if I thought to myself, oh I love
Somali people, then I would try and make friends with that person.
>> Mm-hm.
[LAUGH]
>> Versus someone else was like, oh I can't stand
them and then you know, whatever else happens from there on.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> So I don't, it, at that point it depends on what the attitude is.
>> Mm hmm
>> Of the person, or of the people in
a certain area towards others at that point in time.
>> Sure, and actually that's really interesting that you
say it like that, I mean when you moved to
San Francisco, and you see, you know? Okay, now
your part of a, a minority group and, Do people,
you know, use skin color in the same way, as far as signifiers, in, in the San
Francisco area? I mean, you know? In the
same way that you say, I mean. Where you're
from, you can use it as, like, an
indicator of, you know? Maybe, what region an individual's
from. Do you find that people do the same
thing in San Fransico, or do they, or not?
>> I'm surprisingly oblivious to it.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> Like, because I think I've grown up being used to not having to think
about whether I was the only person to look the way I look in a
room. I tend to do the same thing here, I'll walk in somewhere and think
to myself, oh why are they looking at me? I must have something in my hair.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> Something in my teeth, that I should brushed my teeth well at the house.
>> Right.
>> I don't think to myself, oh my godness, I'm
the only person in here that has darker skin pigmentation.
>> Yeah.
>> And so it takes me awhile, and so I can't I don't know. I have no idea.
>> Yeah
>> Someone else would have to watch.
>> Do you think of skin pigmentation or
skin color as a positive or a negative trait?
>> I don't think of skin pigmentation as a negative or a positive thing,
it does have its advantages in some situations. So,
if you have darker skin pigmentation you've got into
the sun a lot more then someone who doesn't
then you're less likely to get cancer, skin cancer.
>> Do you think of skin color, skin pigmentation
is a positive or a negative trait in anyway?
>> I think skin color can have positives, I
don't think of it as negative or positive, specifically.
>> Mm hm, sure.
>> But I do know that, when I go out in the sun, I have the advantage of
not burning or, I know that I'm less likely
to get skin cancer than someone with lighter skin pigmentation.
>> Mm hm.
>> But on the other side, I do know that, it, you do need the sun
in order for your body to produce vitamin D.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And in that case, if you have
a higher skin, if you have darker skin pigmentation.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Then, you're less, you're more likely to
not have the ability to produce enough vitamin D.
>> Right, exactly, and I know that there
are some people who actually have to take
vitamin D supplements, or they have to actually
be told to go out into the sun more.
>> Mm hmm.
>> To get
enough sunlight.
>> Mm hmm.
>> so that they can make enough vitamin D and that's even true for, for
light skinned people too sometimes who, if you don't get out in the sun enough
you know I believe even on ships when people crossed
the Atlantic in the 15, 1600s, that, that was the
thing right. They stayed if, if you didn't get enough
sunlight, they call it scurvy, right? It's a vitamin D deficiency.
>> Right.
>> And really, the solution is just get out in the sun more.
>> Mm-hm.
>> What are there any other, is there
any other positive or negative aspect, do you think,
sorry, I should say this. Do you think
other people look at skin color or skin pigmentation
as a positive or negative trait? Maybe not so much
from the biological side, but from even a social perspective?
>> Yeah, definitely. There are people who, who, there are people who
think that their skin pigmentation is a positive thing.
>> Mm hm.
>> Or a negative thing. Whereas, if you're ostracised, or you're discriminated
against, for the color of your skin, then you might to start
to think that it's a negative thing.
>> Mm hm.
>> Where is if it's helping you in
life in general, then you'll think it's a positive
thing. So depending on whether you know if I'm
making it in life, so to speak because of
the color of my skin, then I'm going to
be very happy with my skin pigmentation. Versus if,
it's the thing that's causing other people to react
negatively towards me and that's a social thing. Then
I'm going to start to hate the color
of my skin, which is terrible because it's, it's
a genetic trait that has nothing to do with who I am on the inner inside. So.
>> Yeah. I, I completely understand that.
>> Right.
>>
So as you mentioned, the darkly pigmented people are way less likely to get
skin cancer, I think the number is,
like, they're, If you have lighter skin, you're
500 times more likely to get skin cancer. Do you know anyone from Kenya who
had skin cancer at all? Just trying
to see if, reality bears out those statistics.
>> I don't, I don't personally know anyone.
>> Mm-hm. Is that ever a concern? Did, did
they, I don't know if they have like, you know,
in the United States, you know we have
these people who are like, oh, put sunscreen on
go outside put sunscreen on make sure you
put sunscreen on. Do people say that in Kenya?
>> No. I don't hear that too much. sunscreen is also expensive.
[LAUGH]
So.
>> True.
>> I think if it was. I think if people, there were
more cases of skin cancer, the cost would not be an issue.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But, people just think to themselves, I my grandmother lived without
it, my mother lived without it, I'll be fine without it probably.
>> Mm-hm. In Kenya, is sickle cell anemia a common trait?
>> I
don't know how common it is, but I do
know of people who've had it, or who have it.
>> Yeah, and what are the symptoms of sickle cell anemia, or what
was it like for those people that you know of who, who've had it?
>> It was, something I didn't know
was happening until they told me themselves.
>> Mm-hm.
>> with one person I always thought to myself that she looked a
little sickly sometimes but I just thought that maybe she had a cold.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But, turns out that she had, or has
sickle cell anemia.
>> Mm-hm, is it, is it a big
deal? I mean, does it seriously affect their lives?
>> I'm not sure. I'm not sure if it does. I would imagine it does,
but she's very private with it, and so I don't know how much it affected her.
All in all, she seemed to function normally. You know, she would show up to
class, and go through everything that we would
go through and then I'd think to myself,
oh, she's sick again?
>> Mm-hm. Is the new one. no one in your
family, though, has ever been affected by sickle cell anemia?
>> No.
>> That you know of.
>> No, not in family.
>> Do you know if you're a carrier for sickle cell anemia?
>> I do know that, and I'm not.
>> That's great. does that factor into any people's decisions
about, you know, children? Do people worry about that having sickle cell anemia?
>> I
would imagine that in a family where it was common where it
had been running through the family that they might consider it. But I've
never heard of people getting that test because with some people they know
it's not. It's more common in some tribes than it is in others.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And so I think in a tribe like mine where it
rarely happens, I don't see why, I don't think they'd factor in sickle-cell
anemia or whether they were carriers or not into who they would marry.
>> Do you know of, the treatment for sickle cell anemia,
I mean, for people who have it in Kenya, is it generally
accessible, I mean is it, do people know about it, is
it something that's able to be treated in general for most people?
>> So, in a country like Kenya with a rural population that may be
less literate.
>> Mm-hm.
>> They would be less likely to know about treatment
options than a population that was more urban or more literate.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Not necessarily the same thing, but more literate.
>> They would know more and would have access
to treatment, so it depends on the region as well.
>> Mm-hm. Kagure, why is sickle-cell anemia en,
endemic to regions like Kenya in, in Africa.
>> I think
it's something that developed in order to I think it's
something that developed as your, your body's response,
or our body's response to a fight or stave off for malaria.
>> Say say just say to
resistant to malaria. It exists. Well it exists. It's higher
on the region because it also provides some resistance to malaria.
>> Okay. So it's higher in the region
because it provides resistance, some resistance to malaria.
>> So, malaria is a common, sickness.
>> Yes, definitely.
>> Definitely.
>> I've had malaria, everyone else in my family has had malaria too, so.
>> Really?
What's it like to have malaria?
>> you, malaria is like the flu. I've never had the flu, but from what people
describe the flu as, you get dizzy, you
get nauseous, you get achy joints. when I
had malaria, I remember being very dizzy, dizzy
enough that the floor seemed very far away
and like it was teetering. And you're just kind of out of it, you get a
fever, the usual.
>> And how does the, I mean how does
malaria spread. We'll wrap up by our conversation of skin
pigmentation, and what I want to do is just give
you an opportunity to, to tell us anything you might
want to share, you know a lot of people have,
a lot of people think differently about skin color. Some
people it's a big deal, other people it's not a
big deal. If you could give advice or just say
anything speaking to that idea in people about whether or not skin color's a
big deal or not. what would you say or what advice would you give?
>> I think the advice I'd give is that it
shouldn't matter. It would be naive of me to say
that you should ignore it because others are not ignoring
it, and so you should be aware of how others will
treat you but all in all it doesn't,
it shouldn't change who, it doesn't change who you
are on the inside, it's. A genetic trait that
simply dictates what the color of your skin, and
so, after that, it may have it's biological advantages
or disadvantages. But in the end, it doesn't, it
doesn't, your skin color is not your ethnicity, it
isn't your race. Race is a social construct and
so, it doesn't change who you are on the inside. It really
shouldn't matter and it would be great to say that it doesn't matter,
but to some it does. My advice would be to be you, be
who you are. I mean, nobody, nobody cares to be who you are.